primera Cumbre entre la Unión Europea y
Ucrania primera vez que se produce en un
país en guerra en que sobre todo lo que
se ha tratado es de enviar un claro
mensaje por parte de la Unión Europea de
que cueste lo que cueste la Unión
Europea seguirá apoyando a Ucrania
Incluso un año después de la guerra en
la reunión que sucedió después de la que
se produjo ayer entre miembros de la
comisión Europea y del gobierno
ucraniano hoy se han podido aprobar
nuevas cuestiones Como por ejemplo 500
millones de euros más para el envío de
armas a Ucrania también se trata de
entrenar a más de 15.000 soldados
ucranianos en territorio europeo entre
los que se incluye el entrenamiento de
los tanques leopardos además se han
hecho avances para integrar a Ucrania
más en el mercado único europeo y
también en políticas y programas
europeos el objetivo es tener a Ucrania
lo máximo integrada posible la Unión
Europea mientras Sigue esperando y se
produzcan las negociaciones para entrar
dentro de la Unión Y es que
indudablemente la adhesión de Ucrania
dentro de la Unión Europea ha sido uno
de los puntos principales tanto de la
reunión de hoy como la de ayer el
presidente ucraniano voldemir zelensky
ha mostrado su deseo para que las
negociaciones empiecen este mismo año
pero para ellos se necesita tener una
serie de avances Que de momento aún no
se han producido Bruselas valora
positivamente que ha habido algunos
progresos pero no han sido suficientes
en cualquier caso la comisión europea se
ha comprometido a dar un pequeño
análisis en primavera para hablar de
Cuáles han sido los avances por parte de
Ucrania en esta cuestión finalmente
también se ha hablado de un futuro
paquete de sanciones se Tratará ya del
décimo la presencia de la comisión
europea Úrsula fonder Legend ha mostrado
su intención que para el próximo 24 de
febrero primer aniversario desde la
invasión de Ucrania este paquete de
sanciones ya está preparado tendrá un
impacto económico de 10.000 millones de
euros ha avanzado fonder layer entre los
que se incluirán mayores divisiones de
exportaciones de componentes
tecnológicos entre los que se incluyen
componentes de drones algo que ya se
produjo en anteriores rondas de
sanciones pero también como evitar que
Rusia pueda sortear las sanciones